maintenant on va parler de
reconnaissance faciale parce que cette
semaine san francisco est devenue la
première ville américaine à bannir
l'utilisation d'outils de reconnaissance
faciale par la police et par d'autres
agences municipales donc des
technologiques sont au centre vraiment
d'un débat- en ceux qui veulent s'en
servir pour des raisons de sécurité mais
d'autres qui s'inquiètent des risques en
matière de respect de la vie privée donc
renault à wenger a gagné 6 pour nous en
parler bonjour renault bonjour carolina
tout d'abord pourquoi est ce que on a
senti le besoin d'interdire la
reconnaissance faciale à ce qu'on
pensait d'abord faut dire que c'est une
décision qui change rien à court terme
parce que la police de san francisco à
l'utiliser pas la reconnaissance faciale
il ya que dans cette wilaya que
l'aéroport qui l'utilisaient et eux sont
sous juridiction fédérale donc cette
règle vaut pas s'appliquer
donc c'est plus une fois préventives qui
va empêcher la ville d'acquérir cette
technologie là l'avenir
et si les élus ont senti que il était
temps d'agir c'est parce que la
reconnaissance faciale au fait des
progrès immenses au cours des dernières
années
donc n'importe qui avec un téléphone et
et qui ont un téléphone intelligent peut
s'en est aperçu on est rendu avec pleins
d'applications que were on peut démarrer
notre cellule avec notre visage on peut
ajouter des caractéristiques drôle à des
images d'une autre phase pendant vidéo
ce cd application drôle mais à l'échelle
d'une ville ou d'un pays ça devient
vraiment plus délicat cette technologie
à la déjà été utilisée par elite
utilisant sûrement par des forces
policières peu partout dans le monde et
sa période et statistiques qui montrent
que ça a permis de procéder à des
arrestations de résoudre certains crimes
mais pour plusieurs personnes une
surveillance de cette ampleur là ça peut
entraîner des risques pour la liberté
d'expression mais ça pourrait aussi
ciblé justement certaines minorités qui
sont déjà stigmatisé vraiment
technologique est devenu très efficace
on investit beaucoup
oui oui ça c'est vraiment une
technologie d'avenir depuis les
dernières années beaucoup de progrès peu
d'investissements qui ont été faits il
faut dire ceux ci seront efficaces à ce
point là c'est parce que ces systèmes
vont pas reconnaître des visages comme
vous et moi on va le faire renoncer les
la reconnaissance faciale va plutôt se
concentrer sur certains détails certains
points comme par exemple la distance
entre chaque oeil et la position des
oreilles au niveau du visage l'espace
entre le nez la bouche des
caractéristiques
les dés qu'elle vaut savoir des quelques
des caractéristiques comme swaps et une
fois qu'il peut identifier tous ces
points clés mais lui va apprendre à
reconnaître un visage dans une foule à
l'aide de cette information-là en la
comparant à des photos qui sont aux
données de photos de base qui sont déjà
dans des bases d'identités avec des
visages et des noms associés et qui sont
déjà associés et comme n'importe quelle
intelligence artificielle ça marchera
pas du premier coup il va lui falloir
une période d'entraînement et pendant
cette période d ivoire pratique avec une
énorme quantité de données les
ingénieurs vont lui fournir des milliers
de photos est ce qui va apprendre
justement reconnaître tous ces détails
là et il va trouver une méthode fiable
pour reconnaître l'identité de n'importe
quelle personne qu'on a obtenu ce qu'on
a retrouvé sur une caméra de
surveillance
une fois que ce système là et prêt à
partir de maintenant plus fournir des à
partir de ce moment on peut lui donner
des informations venant de n'importe
quelle caméra l'échelle d'une ville ou
d'un pays et on pourrait se retrouver de
surveiller sans qu'on le sache
dans au moins deux pays est ce que c'est
c'est infaillible où il peut y avoir
quand même c'est sûr le problème c'est
yoyo délit peut y avoir des problèmes
c'est pas une technologie qui est
parfaite
d'abord depuis les dernières années on
s'est rendu compte que des intelligences
artificielles
malgré leur apparente neutralité ça peut
être biaisé parce que si les données
avec lesquels on a fait toute cette
séance de pratique dont je parlais à 20
mais sont peu représentatifs de
l'ensemble la population ou et
contiennent des stéréotypes racistes ou
sexistes ou défendent la programmation
ben en fait mais tout dépend où ça tout
dépend des données avec laquelle ces
pratiques et donc si cette intelligence
artificielle réfléchir pas avoir répété
les billets qui sont déjà dans les
données qu'on lui fournit donc si on
utilise essentiellement pour dans les
séances de pratique des photos d'hommes
blancs
mais ces intelligences artificielles
pourront avoir de la difficulté à
reconnaître des femmes ou des personnes
assises et et ça ça a été montré dans
certains dans des études une étude
récente qui m'a montré que les femmes à
la peau plus foncée avec ce système la
vente aux d'erreur quand sociale et
reconnaître de 34,7 % comparativement à
1 % pour des hommes blancs donc c'est
une énorme marge
et si ce système est utilisé par des
services de police ben ça pourrait
entraîner les arrestations dans des
communautés dans des arrestations et
justifie dans des minorités qui ont déjà
des relations tendues avec les forces de
police que c'est pour ce risque est là
qu'on a décidé à san francisco sera
embelli saha
c'est pour le risque d'erreur et aussi
pour le risque d'utilisation peu
excessive comme on le voit dans
certaines parties du monde
ça peut rapidement menés à du profilage
de masse en chine par exemple des
enquêtes journalistiques que montrer que
les télés reconnaissance faciale est
utilisé pour repérer certaines minorités
ethniques comme les we go / à cause de
certains traits faciaux
il ya un autre exemple en 2017 et des
chercheurs américains qui ont montrés
que
il avait développé un système de
reconnaissance faciale capable de
reconnaître l'orientation sexuelle juste
avec des traits faciaux c'est sûr que
c'est basé sur des énormes stéréotypes
on y vend bien à la limite entre la
science et l'absolution city mais le
fait qu' il ya des intelligences
artificielles qui puisque les ou qu'ils
puissent classifiés la population ou qui
disent être capables de le faire mais ça
ça vous montre les risques d'intensifier
la répression vécue par ces minorités
donc c'est pour se reposer pour bannir
la reconnaissance faciale
yutz après avoir des points intéressants
mais c'est pour ça que à cause de ses
problèmes éthiques que san francisco a
décidé cette semaine de mettre les
fruits pour ailleurs il ya vraiment une
grande réflexion à faire sur scène